hello everyone we're going Christmas
shopping but first we are going to
Starbucks because of my family's Wi-Fi
is so awful that I try to upload a video
last night didn't work so a lot of
Starbucks upload some videos of course
get a coffee and then do a little bit of
Christmas shopping and I've also got a
few things that I want to get for myself
so we have to go to gamestop because
what should we do I can't see I want to
tell you what I would get but then it's
a Christmas present for somebody so if I
say it there's a small chance they might
watch the video and then it's wuant boy
are you to pause the video who
absolutely knows I could post it right
now I this could be like after Christmas
it's a struggle you know what I need
what I need to wash my hair me too I'm
cutting off half my head because my hair
is disgusting I just don't like to wash
my hair what shoot him GameStop is right
over there let's go he's nice upload yes
and that go shot
baby hey baby hey Vic where are you I
try I see you with my eyes but I don't
see you with my camera would you forget
oh I don't know where it is
I have misplaced it
yeah so my camera is dead but we're
gonna continue this vlog on my iPhone or
an alligator stop be a scarf I am so
pumped up right now I don't even
know what to say other than you I'm
gonna put it on my body here shortly
holy moly could you hold this real quick
yeah
just yeah hold it like right this this
is this is hard vlogging on an iPhone
especially when its front-facing bb8
scarf bb-8 is my dog like he is Maddie
this is incredible you really got this
thing in there Oh y'all go to gamestop
you wanna buy a video game no I bought a
scarf
I'm gonna be summer but let me get up
seriously wow you've got a lot of great
patterns going on today I am
put me in this window
let's go the pet store we're at that go
it does smell pretty terrible
should we get both something for
Christmas well I brought your toys so I
need food something I want to get a gate
do you get yeah our parents keep using
like a cardboard box so they don't feel
like they don't want the gift we don't
want that we don't want that I'm adding
in something cute for the dog Awards he
needs a cute outfit yep those are so
heavy we're continuing on the BBA trend
we just found a dog bb-8 toy so clearly
maddie is gonna be quite pumped up he
doesn't even know that he likes this
this little r2d2 sweater little Ewok
hoodie do you think you would like this
to shape this mr. BAE okay so we're
gonna go with the Archie g2 because from
the back it's gonna look super cute
that's right I don't wanna put a hood on
him he's probably good so he doesn't
have the hood it'll still look cute
dilemma
that's wrong
I got this just
you got this I need a hat I need a hat
because I don't want to wash my hair and
if I have a hat I won't have to wash my
hair because the Hat will cover the dirt
it's on backwards I'll wear this hat Hey
Oh maybe I'm just not a hat person or
maybe I am and I just don't know it
this wasn't exactly the Hat that I had
in mind
oh great Fras here didn't run a hat yeah
but you did you really know she didn't
go look bad in that hat
I just want to look good for you good
for you the wig what am I gonna do what
about one of my options here I mean I
can't well I could wear this the
unfortunate reality is I'm an adult
speaking of being an adult can we go
check out the Lego section yeah I'm
sorry you're that same owner they
probably do read awesome you have to get
Steve a onesie because I promised him
that we would get him one and guess what
I didn't do get him a onesie he said the
last one today I was it was tight in all
the wrong places so I was like and it
was white yeah white and tight right
disaster recipe for disaster whether
you're a male or a female
I'm Jimmy call me daddy might want a new
blanket I feel like soft
over here I see them full-size
stormtroopers and Peter he's talking to
me right now
you know I think I should get the Hat
John I'm kidding me I have to get the
hat what am I gonna do I'm after one my
hair yeah I do look we're in public say
money brought one outfit help I know
this is it it's do you think you don't
like my outfit wear the hat with it we
go this is not sponsored at all but I'm
obsessed with Burt's Bees lip gloss
that's basically all I wear I also only
use actually no that's not this is I use
the yes to face wipes but these are new
lipsticks that they just came out with
could you hold this rope yeah you have
to put it on okay stop walking
you hate it the same as your lips I'm so
basic it hurts like it actually hurts
right now a month I'm I'm in pain right
now we're going to dicks we are heading
to dick we're gonna check out all the
goods that they've got it dicks I've got
a dicks gift card you've got a dick gift
card you're so lucky I'm holding on to a
great year and a half now so what you're
saying is human bones not in your wallet
you've had that dick just show us the
dicks no do so numbers and let's deal
like this don't teach you to stay on my
ex money get off her dick I'll be back
up get off the next money okay oh look
he's nice North Face jacket Jen 25% off
dick so I've got my different
Dick's got lots of hash I want the white
one but it looks good who the black will
match everything
if suddenly I think I might get the gray
the white is a little too little too
risky God we found some good deals at
Dick's I love coming home because
there's always so much hometown sports
gear it's great look that Penn's hat you
think daddy would like that all right
this is a nice that is a nice hat
I think add it to the pile Merry
Christmas dad don't watch this video
let's look at mine oh god this outfit
today is progressively gotten just worse
no it's a good day I'm just saying that
like this worries out of let's go oh oh
god this hat is it's 75 degrees outside
it's cold seven eight er is it is not
seven degrees
it is give me the proof 65 degrees out
the sea okay see we're gonna make this
later it's everything you need is in the
box so hey why don't they just give us
like the crackers that's a good point
I thought because it supposed to be like
oh look I made this oh we have to make
it it's in the bar right okay next stop
is to a giant eagle gram grocery store
so that
so we can get some icing to decorate our
Star Wars cookies I'm so festive I just
can't believe I'm some with all that I
spirit don't see about safety versus you
two yeah but I think leave me alone be
nice to me you're mean look these can be
I could use these for for artoo r2d2
colors maybe some sprinkles please
didn't turn out so well yeah but like
look we've got this right here cookie
icing blue I like me to all the colors
different tips comedy nice house icing
Jenna you're a chef yep it's making us
some grilled cheese and tomato soup I
take my hat off it's very unfortunate
because now this is what we're left with
I'm so excited for the pup to come back
my mom has taken him for a walk and my
dad and I hope hope that he loves this
Kiley run dog toy as much as I do
Maddy look at this what do you think of
the new kylo Ren dog toy tell me what
you think is this something that you
might be into oh you just want to sit in
my lap okay do you like it do you like
it does something you might be into nah
let me tell you a spoiler about the
movie do you me tell you do you and me
tell you who kylo Ren is I would